[Music]
so ladies and gentlemen
some of you may know jeff from online
courses i'm going to hand over to him
please a warm round of applause thank
you very much
thanks everybody i'm super excited to be
here this is my very first r studio conf
so thank you very much for the invite
i'm going to talk a little bit about a
project that we've been doing in
baltimore to use data science to create
new economic opportunities
and so this is a project that's relied
very heavily on tools developed by
our studio and so i'm really grateful
for the all the help that they've
helped us do over the last couple of
years i talked super fast so
you're going to see a lot of slides if
you want to follow along or look at them
later
you can find them at this website so
first i wanted to thank a lot of people
who
took a gamble on this project and in
particular i really wanted to thank
three
four people shannon ellis abizar hadavan
jamie mcgovern and ashley johnson who
i had this completely hair brained idea
to do this project
and they all gambled on me with the
project and i really appreciate their
their time and then you'll hear about
some of the other people that have
gambled on us and and hopefully it's
paid off for them
so they're the real mvps of the talk
that i am giving to here i'm just the
the mouthpiece
so this whole project has felt a lot
like this every you know this is a
project i'll tell you it has a lot of
moving parts and it's felt like at the
you know throughout the project we're a
train going down a track and we're
rapidly trying to get uh debris off the
track so that we don't go off
and all the people that i just showed
you a minute ago are people that helped
us
solve problems so as you've probably
heard or know
and or you've read about in the news
recently uh income inequality is a
big problem in the world and i work in a
school of public health and it turns out
income inequality is also a public
health
problem if you look this is actual real
data i know it's
the line is so straight it looks like i
made it up this is real data
it is the relationship between how much
money you make and what your life
expectancy is based on census records
for the entire united states
if you make at the 80th percentile on
average you live between five and seven
years longer
than people who make at the 20th
percentile this is a correlation of
course not causation
but this is an incredibly tight
correlation and it also
relates to every other public health
consequence that you might imagine
so at the same time that economic
inequality could cause
some concern for us about public health
differences and disparities
economic mobility is also at a record
low so this is a map
produced by the harvard group raj
teddy's group looking at economic
mobility in the united states
and this is the neighborhood around
where i work at johns hopkins johns
hopkins is a massive multi-billion
dollar institution with a lot of very
well paid doctors
but the median income for a person that
grows up in the neighborhood around our
uh hospital is 18 000 for family at the
age of 34.
so that and not only that but the chance
of going from that income to going up to
a higher level of income is very
small this isn't just a problem in
cities this is i grew up in pocatello
idaho which is a random little town in
idaho
and there's a similar hey there's some
pocatellons find me later
uh so and this is a similar kind of
economic
mobility challenge even in rural parts
of the united states
it turns out that the best way to solve
the economic mobility problem the best
intervention anybody's ever invented is
education
but it turns out that you need access to
education in order to be able to take
advantage of this intervention
so if you see it plot on the x-axis how
easy it is to get into a university
and on the y-axis how likely it is
you'll be in the 80th percentile or
above
income after you finish you see that
there's this kind of l shape
the easier it is to get into the less
money you make when you get out
the harder it is to get into the more
money you'll make when you get out
technical education obviously breaks
this trend and gives us an opportunity
to inexpensive education
and move people up the economic mobility
ladder this whole project is predicated
on the hypothesis that talent is evenly
distributed but opportunity isn't
so we've been teaching data science
online for a little while now we've
taught more than five million people on
the coursera platform forum in
just straight data science using r we've
also taught six million plus across a
variety of different data science
modalities
and so that's something we're really
excited about and really proud of
but one thing that we wanted to know is
could people use these programs to
improve their economic prospects
so we did a study and we looked at what
people's income was before they took our
program
and after and so the green dots which
you probably can't see too well but are
up in this top left-hand corner
are people who had below poverty level
income but ended up at above the 80th
percentile of income
after taking a 1 000 online program that
they took in their spare time
that was a very very small subset of our
coursera
students but it's a pretty inspiring
subset of those coursera students
so it turns out though that almost
everybody that takes our coursera
classes
are already educated you know the most
common uh
user of one of our corsair classes is a
upper middle class white male silicon
valley engineer so there's probably a
few around here
um and which is great and we love
educating those folks but it's not
reaching
the broad audience so even if you build
it they won't necessarily come to the
massive online open courses
so we started thinking about from first
principles how do we take somebody who's
maybe never heard of data science
and turn them into a functioning data
scientist who can get a job and improve
their economic prospects
so these are the challenges that we came
up with shannon and abazar and sean
who's sitting here in the front
uh talked to about this a lot uh back in
my office a few years ago
and so we thought an expensive computer
is a challenge
uh it's been said that a data scientist
is a statistician working on a macbook
pro
that'll run you about three thousand
dollars for a macbook pro but if your
income last year as a family was five
thousand dollars you're not buying a
macbook pro
so we wanted to build a program that
could be run on any computer that has an
internet connection and a web browser
so this is where we relied heavily we
were the initial beta testers tariff and
robbie
helped us out a lot got us on our studio
cloud helped us scale this whole program
that was the only way we would be able
to do that
so we've been doing data science on a
chromebook for a while you can do it
with google slides
google sheets but the real hero of this
story in terms of technology is our
studio
cloud so we ran our whole new mooc
sequence we built an entirely new mooc
sequence entirely based on our studio
cloud so that anybody could take it you
could go to the public library and take
our data science series on the
web browser then you'd have to know
about data science everyone here knows
about data science
but if you go talk to a lot of the
people in the community where i'm where
we have run this program they've never
heard of that they don't know it's a
thing they don't know you could do
something with it they don't know you
could improve your life with it
so we had to tell people about that and
again this is the same problem we had
before
most people who are taking these online
courses are already educated so they
hear about data science
this is a not exclusive to us if you've
heard of a data science boot camp or
lambda school or any of these other
things
if you look at the data on who's being
educated by these programs it's very
strongly concentrated among already
educated folks
so we went out and partnered with a
non-profit in east baltimore just off
the block where we work
uh historic east baltimore community
action coalition
and so they're amazing and they have a
ged training program and so
they also have access to a catchment
area of a lot of
really talented youth who maybe not had
not heard about data science
so we worked with them to identify some
people and to tell them about data
science
then we needed an appropriate program so
the cool thing about the tools that have
been built by
uh r is that they you know with a
relatively little amount of overhead
you can go from nothing to magic and so
we can compress
programmed uh training programs that
make people very capable down into very
short periods of time
with this much code you can build a
funny little website with this much code
you can build an interactive dashboard
on the nhanes
data with this much code you can access
a gigantic database and process
thousands and thousands or millions and
millions of records
and you can scrape data um or or connect
to apis you know all of the things that
the pr
packages have been uh uh we've been
early adopters of all of them
so we built a program called cloud-based
data science anybody can take it it's
online it's free go to
clouddatascience.org
we have tons of people taking it all
over the world um
but we also partnered with a non-profit
this
non-profit to run the program locally in
baltimore so we had our content
development starting in february 2018
april 2018 we had our first meeting with
yo the hebc's training program
uh they said hey this is great we should
start tomorrow
we had started content development on
february 2018 so we said
uh maybe next month and they said okay
may 21st it is
so remember i had to build a whole
training program
and we had a month to do it so this was
me in my office
after that meeting trying to figure out
how we would do it fortunately
uh we had this amazing team of people
who developed content for us in a
distributed way
and the you know shannon ellis and abzar
had a van der serve the lion's share of
the credit in terms of content
development
but um what was amazing is we actually
had technologies developed by sean cross
and by um john michelle
that allowed us to develop and deploy
this content very quickly
so then we've solved a couple of
problems but there are still some
problems out there
we still got to get them a computer
access to instruction income security so
we have
trained developed this training program
um and we wanted to be able to do it
very quickly so that we could give them
this kind of access
we have this is a github repo that is
the 34 000 repos
of our getting and cleaning data final
projects for our coursera class you can
go online and see all the 34 000
projects people have done
if you look at what libraries were used
in the development of this
uh course uh you'll notice there was a
strong trend for one package it's the d
plier package this package was released
the day i released my getting and
cleaning data course and rendered the
entire course obsolete on coursera on
day one
thanks hadley very much appreciate that
so
we learned our lesson and first we
monitor everything that our studio
people are doing at all times while
we're building courses
but second sean built some really
awesome technologies that allowed us to
automatically synthesize the voices
around our videos and automatically
generate all of our videos and all of
our moocs from
our markdown documents and from google
slides so we can recompile
and re-release new courses very very
rapidly to be able to deploy this
program
similarly all of our tutorials are built
in an amazing program called swirl also
developed by sean and nick
carchetti who i don't think is here that
allows us to write sort of markdown like
uh yaml-like uh tutorials that people
can then interactively take in r
so we wanted to go after this new cohort
with which comes from a different sort
of
level of education and from a different
background so we built a training
program
that has in-person office hours three
hours a week you get paid to complete
the courses you get a free chromebook
and then we help you with job assistance
i get up very very early in the morning
because i have young kids and my postdoc
goes to sleep very very late because he
doesn't have young kids and so
you get basically 24-hour slack support
uh when you're taking our
courses um and then we partnered with
nam uh
yo and they provided the real work which
is like wrap around services housing
support things like that for people who
needed it
um and then we decided to run a pilot so
we ran it with i was gonna run it with
20 people and joe chang came to visit
uh us in baltimore and he said that is a
terrible idea try two first
and so we did we tried it with two
people the learning started may 21st
how long should the program take we
don't know we just made this up last
week so
we said three months which is a
dramatically short timeline to learn a
lot of data science
um especially for people who had never
heard of data science and were already
looking at us a little skeptically to
start
surprisingly even with these challenges
of us basically being behind in content
development
the both of the candidates finished the
program in four months
the new cohorts have finished in the
three months we originally projected
because now we're content is done
instead of
like the first course cohort where they
weren't so we've had
multiple cohorts go through this and
we've had an 80 success rate
this is an incredible success rate given
that the people that we're working with
have never heard about data science
beforehand
and it's really a testament to the
incredibly talented people that we're
working with who just didn't have an
opportunity to do this
and now you know they pick it up you
know way faster they're teaching me
stuff now
so the next challenge that we had is we
wanted to use this as an economic
intervention but if you've ever seen a
job ad for a data scientist
these are your actual roles and
responsibilities
but these are the job requirements
and so that's a bit of a problem when
we're training people to do really
powerful good useful stuff but the job
requirements look like that
it's true for this is i'm picking on
someone in particular in the baltimore
area but this is you know you need a
bachelor's degree in five years of
experience and what they really needed
was somebody to look into their sql
databases and like figure out what's
going on
so it turns out there's a problem with
us directly employing the data
scientists we've changed if they don't
have a bachelor's degree one
you know one of the people that's
completed our program has had a
bachelor's degree
he's actually here today somewhere in
the back there he is anthony
you should go talk to him later and
antonio who's also here
completed our program is getting his
bachelor's degree and he's going to be a
doctor someday as fast as he possibly
can
um but the fair labor in standard acts
uh doesn't you know has these carve outs
for who can be a
salaried employee i learned a lot about
hr law
through this project and it turns out
data scientist doesn't meet the software
engineering requirement for the fair
labor and standards that
be an exempt employee i've talked to a
lot of lawyers about this
so this is a problem because now you
have to hire the folks that we've
trained as hourly employees
so i was this close i've trained
incredibly talented people who are super
smart can do incredible things
but they don't have a job that they can
get because
the labor laws require them to be an
hourly job but they're being listed as
salary jobs and
so i'm in a big a bit of a pickle i work
at hopkins and i'm a faculty member and
when you're a faculty member at a place
like hopkins you can pitch a fit and try
to get them to do things for you
and so i did that and i have over the
last year and a half pitched enough fits
that they've created a new job
classification just last week
so that people that complete our
training program can be employed at
johns hopkins as data scientists so
very excited about that but thank you
very much yeah that i feel like i should
get the applause for battling the hr
system and winning so um
so but in the meantime we didn't have a
place for people to be employed even
though they're super talented
well turns out a lot of people were
emailing me to do data science
consulting work because i'm on coursera
all the time and i used to just hit
delete on all those emails sorry
but then i had an amazing outreach from
some folks at um this guy zach jerome
from wyden kennedy
and he said hey right at the time when i
was launching this he said hey do you
want to do some stuff together
they might a couple of people from wk
might be here who we work with a lot
they're amazing
and they we so we've started to work
with companies like that
and to basically do data science as a
service for them and so
what we found in doing that is with a
lot of companies wk is
one of the best case scenarios in a lot
of the cases we work with companies the
main problem is the data isn't organized
as everyone knows 80
of the problem is data cleaning so we've
kind of created a
product which is tidy data as a service
we call it streamline
um but the idea is basically we go in
and build a custom set of pipelines that
pull everybody's data in put it in a
database every night and so they have
the clean
data that they need to use and so we've
been
deploying this the the team you should
meet antonio and anthony in the back
they're super talented
hire them away from us please and then
i'll train more um
and so we founded this company and we
decided we were gonna put it right in
the neighborhood where this is happening
so our company is headquartered like
right up the block from hopkins we're
hiring data scientists from this
training program
and we think of that as their first data
science opportunity but they're so
talented that's definitely not going to
be their last data science opportunity
so this is the project we set out to try
to accomplish we've
tackled each of this bit by bit it's
still a little bit held together with
sticks and mud and glue and the
hard work of anthony antonio and their
friends um
but we're taking a big swing at how do
we tackle getting our studio and r
and these sort of talents just like carl
mentioned how do we use this as an
engine to create economic opportunities
for people who wouldn't otherwise have
them in this area
and tackle these big public health
problems head on so
um if you want to read more about this
again jtleaks.comtalks they wrote a nice
little article about us
um and then if you want to get involved
we would love for you to reach out to us
about
being a mentor hiring a graduate of our
program becoming a customer of our
company
or donating to help us train more people
in data science and thank you very much
for your attention
okay so having set a new rstudio conf
record for syllables per second
yes um first question that comes up
where can people get training in all the
stuff you had to learn that wasn't data
science you mentioned
hr i imagine there's a whole bunch of
other things you have to run this
project to do
things like this uh that's a good
question
i i'm not sure i'd recommend that
someone go and try to learn all those
things
um what it is is you know it's this the
reason why we called the company problem
forward is because we think about
problem forward not solution backward
we're trying to like figure out what's
the problem and then solve the barriers
instead of like try ending up with the
solution and like
reverse engineering it and what i found
in not only this project but every
project is
if you pick a project at an endpoint you
really or a project you really care
about a problem you really care about
you just have to learn a whole bunch of
stuff that is unrelated you wish you
could it would just be our scripting but
it never is
yeah okay next question how has
all of this changed what you teach and
how you teach
at the university yeah so the the online
courses were actually
we were kind of t i've been teaching
this advanced data science course at
johns hopkins for years
using r in our studio and stuff like
that before coursera
um then we did coursera and now we've
been coursera
and online programs like leanpub and
coursera have been kind of our like
it's like our education labs we like run
it there first try it out see how it
works
learn all the things that go wrong when
a thousand people try to learn it that
way and then kind of
build it back into our local in-person
program so it's kind of a cool
yeah way to do that okay and one last
question and this one's from me
um if you could send email back in time
to the day you first thought of doing
this what would you tell yourself
uh so many things but i think the first
thing that i would say is
uh be super grateful to all the people
that took the gamble with you on this
like i said a lot of people kind of
gambled with their careers to help me do
this and i
deeply appreciate that um and then the
second thing i think i would have said
and this is a true story is jj talked
about creating an economic engine that
allows him to do other things first
and i didn't generate the economic
engine first and that has been
challenging i wish i had done economic
engine first social mission section
second but uh you know uh it's still
working out
so i'm not sure that's a hard and fast
thing but it's a nice idea so
thanks all right one more round of
applause for jeff in this program
you